hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics rationally
been on the road for a couple weeks and
so I was going to give my class the
other day
but uh I couldn't trust the internet so
I decided to postpone it
and it's a good thing I did because on
that day they shut down all the
electricity in in the place where I was
at uh several parts of the Town were
turned off
uh no electricity whatsoever and you
discover then
how important electricity is to the
cities
in the country probably water is more
important but in the cities it's like
water we take for granted it's always
there
uh all the piping is there you know
but you don't have electricity
everything runs on electricity you have
no fridge you have no uh lights
you have no phone no Internet you're
dead
so uh yeah keep that in mind if we lose
electricity
uh
forget about the The Day the Earth Stood
Still you know it's it's like you know
you can't do anything because everything
runs on electricity even the cars right
now
okay anyways um uh what are we gonna do
today well we're gonna do uh
uh motion we're gonna talk about motion
what is motion
and then we're gonna listen to our
science critic he's gonna tell us
something about knowledge and truth and
science I guess he's an expert and all
that so we're gonna listen to him and
I'm gonna open the floor for questions
but let's begin with our extension
segment
and uh you know there was a uh disease
in the 19th century
it uh known as yellow fever
and he killed lots of people people were
afraid of it Etc and uh today
uh there's a modification of that uh
disease
and people are very scared of it it's
known as yellow fear
everybody and their mother is scared of
China
China's taking over the world and people
are so scared
they don't know what to think
they're they're worried you know so we
call it yellow fear okay and here are
some examples okay here's the first one
we have China slams U.S on debt limit in
accuses Washington of sabotage
and essentially says that the Chinese
Embassy one of them there in Zambia
blasted the U.S over its catastrophic
death problem an accused it of
sabotaging other nations efforts to
resolve debt problems the embassy said
the biggest contribution that the U.S
can make to the debt issue outside the
country is to act on responsible
monetary policies cope with its own debt
problem and stop sabotaging other
Sovereign countries active efforts to
solve their debt issues
and so it says there that the treasury's
measures give it space for some months
before it runs out of cash okay
Economist and bond market analysts
anticipate the ceiling will have to be
raised sometime in the third quarter to
avert a U.S payments default okay which
is damaging for the world's biggest
economy as well as the Global Financial
system
so uh that's the accusation that the
Chinese launched against the United
States
and on the other side on the western
side you know people are worried about
China again you know this yellow fear
and this is what one fellow has to say
about it
what he recommends he says freeing the
U.S economy from China will create an
American industrial Renaissance and
millions of good paying jobs
father thinks that the United States can
go back to Manufacturing
you know here we have uh Indo West
almost every country every Advanced
Nation about 80 85 percent of their
economies are services
manufacturing has been you know muscled
out of the economy out of the gross
national product and GDP you know and it
turns out that uh you know all these uh
countries only have like 15 to 20
percent of their economy both in terms
of Labor and in terms of
um GDP is
is manufacturing a relatively small
percentage before World War II
you know you have had much higher
percentages of manufacturing but slowly
and slowly the manufacturing age died
off industrialization came downwards and
what took off with services
as people uh you know as a lot of the uh
corporations become became automated and
assembly lines and so on and they could
produce things more efficiently you know
they pushed people out of the
manufacturing jobs the blue collar uh
jobs into white collar jobs and so all
the jobs today or most of them are
services and economy is mainly Services
agriculture came down to one or two
percent maybe three in some countries
you know it's a small percentage of the
global economy and uh especially of the
advanced Nations and uh a small
percentage of GDP as well
Hunter Gathering we don't do that
anymore maybe some tribe out there you
know it used to be a hundred percent
just uh 50 000 years ago 100 uh Hunter
Gathering was
the top uh activity uh 100 of people
engaged in that type of job job or
Market or mode of production now it's
practically gone
anyway it says uh this fellow wants to
decouple the uh from the Chinese economy
you know and says now uh decoupling from
China now could launch an American
industrial Renaissance and also create
millions of uh good paying U.S jobs
after 20 years it's clear that trade
liberalization has failed to transform
China into an ally a partner or even a
more Democratic Society in fact the
opposite has happened
okay and he says with Beijing already
massively subsidizing its state-owned
companies it makes no sense to allow
each uh continued duty-free access such
a continued Duty access so he wants to
um
He suggests he's recommending that uh
you know they increase tariffs on
Chinese products and maybe that way
that's been always the policy of
different countries you raise tariffs
and that way you protect the local
industry meaning they can operate more
inefficiently right because you're
protecting them through tariffs from
outside uh Commerce okay
and okay so that's what this fall
suggests uh not everybody agrees with
that they a lot of people are free
marketers uh they say you know the
market should be totally free this
person says no let's protect our
industry a lot of people don't like that
and here's uh you know he uh he suggests
that here's one case that I've talked
about in the past here's another article
on that and that is that the the U.S
needs more than Chip's act to stay ahead
of China from an MIT report says America
used to be the leader in chip
manufacturing or fabrication that is as
it's known they're talking about not
potato chips they're talking about
integrated circuits but it now builds
just 12 percent of the world's
semiconductors so you can see that it's
a relatively small percentage for such a
big country
and uh even though the government has
taken steps to limit China's ability you
know to access high-end American
Technologies uh they would like to keep
you know China
um downwards not getting all the uh
equipment necessary to manufacture uh
high-end chips it says there it says the
Commerce department is getting set to
announce how companies can apply for
funds from the multi-billion project
okay so they're creating a fund there
which is aimed at what bringing more
semiconductor manufacturing back to the
U.S and incentivizing firms to research
uh cutting-edge technologies that will
give American companies an edge over
International Rivals primarily China
obviously and follow says if the
government and American businesses
managed to come together the country
should be able to hold on to its lead in
the tech industry
if not China will likely grab the lead
in its business businesses and Military
will supplant the us as the Top Dog on
the international stage
okay so they're worried a little bit
about this you know this yellow fear
um
that China might surpass the United
States in chip manufacturing not only in
quantity but also in quality okay in
other words that they achieve
um Cutting Edge technology level okay
and so uh what's the result they're
they're creating because they've already
created this uh there's a plant in Ohio
and another one in Arizona that they're
building I think there will be
operational by the year 24 or 26
thereabouts uh where the United States
is again trying to manufacture its own
chips and not
um
you know uh give them to other countries
like Taiwan which is close to China you
know imagine that happens to fall what
would happen especially to the car
industry that relies and chips so much
uh so that they're trying to get a lot
of that manufacturing back and the
question is yeah they can do that the
question is will that be subsidized
first because they're talking about you
know the United States government
working with Private Industry meaning
subsidizing uh
and it kind of makes you think whether
they're defeating the purpose the United
States Prides itself as being a country
that functions on uh pure capitalism
but here we're they're taking the road
that China took which is government and
Industry work to gather hand in hand to
protect the country's interests
and so it's like uh they're more into
the mixed economy than they are in you
know in either capitalism or communism
uh neither China's Communists neither
the United States is capitalists they're
all kind of in the center you know they
have all these mixed economies where you
know wherever it's needed government
intervenes and helps Industries either
through tariffs or by subsidizing them
or whatever it whatever it takes to uh
maintain the lead especially in high-end
Technologies so
um they're all becoming the same the
same East and West that's why I take no
no part in any side you know I think
they're all the same they're all tyrants
they're all they're all run their
economies in the same way more or less
there is no free market out there
especially for the important products
that a country wants to defend you know
those are all to some degree protected
subsidized Etc
and so they're all coming up with the
same uh form of government or economic
system
whether you uh believe that or not well
that's what I believe they're all the
same okay here's a couple more examples
China fear
yellow fever yellow fever okay here's uh
the telegraph from England says uh
our Global Order is in deep trouble and
they're talking about the Soviet Union
turning into Russia and Russia and China
coming together and they're working
together against the West okay but it
says when one of the permanent uh one of
the five permanent members of the U.N
security Council illegally invades
another state another permanent member
then refuses to condemn that Invasion
and the other three offer no Collective
strategy to check this blatant breach of
international law then Humanity has
entered a dark unpredictable chapter
and it says that both Putin and she uh
both feel threatened by what an
international
rules-based order that calls for greater
freedoms Democratic accountability and
transparency
okay and so um
they say well you know uh the West is
democratic his guys has freedoms etc etc
but uh these uh Eastern Nations you know
Russia and China primarily uh they don't
have that okay
and I don't know about that again I I
have my grave doubts let me give you an
example of uh democracy and freedom okay
here you have it okay
here we have the Rabbani Brothers they
leave Guantanamo Bay without charge
after almost 20 years two brothers from
Pakistan who were held in the U.S
military prisoner at Guantanamo Bay for
nearly 20 years have been released
without charge Abdullah Muhammad Rabbani
were arrested in Pakistan in 2002. the
Pentagon said Rabbani operated in Al
Qaeda safe house while his brother
organized travel and funds for the
group's leaders and for this they got
these this 20 years but they weren't
tried they weren't sent to you know a
judge or anything like that they were
just captured and put away
uh the brothers alleged they were
tortured by CIA officers before being
transferred to Guantanamo in 2013 Ahmed
began a series of hunger strikes that
lasted for seven years he would survive
on nutritional supplements sometimes
forcibly fed to him through a tube both
men were approved for a release in 2021
it is unclear why they remained
imprisoned both have now been
repatriated to Pakistan
um what is it called freedom and
democracy
Justice I mean you know obviously they
are terrorists because they wear beards
and uh mustache you know they're
obviously terrorists but uh where is
this Freedom that they talk about in uh
rule of law and all this other stuff
I mean you know it sounds a lot like
what Hitler did when Germany uh invaded
Poland the uh made these concentration
camps and they would take uh citizens
and non-citizens alike you know from
Germany out there you know where they
were beyond the law of the land they
didn't want to get in trouble with the
law of the land so as long as you did it
in uh Poland and you did it over there
with the military and the uh gestapo and
all these other people you know the SS
uh then it's okay you know you do that
all secretly and people don't hear about
it and they don't see it and so it's all
okay because you can't bring charges and
you're not be and if you're one of the
persons who goes to one of these prisons
or concentration camps or whatever you
want to call them well no you know you
have no rights and you can't challenge
it in court because you're isolated from
the legal system
and that seems like what antonomo looks
like you know uh I mean be honest what
is Guantanamo uh why don't they have it
in Florida or in California or New York
no no it had to be out there beyond the
reach of the law the long arm of the law
right
and here's another instance okay it says
protest in Berlin over arming Ukraine
against Russia draws thousands maybe it
was hundreds of thousands but they said
it was ten thousand and I guess that's
to some degree immaterial but it says I
want you to look at this as police
mobilize a thousand four hundred
officials to keep the peace and to
enforce what bans on military uniforms
Russian and Soviet Flags Russian
military songs and right-wing symbols in
other words
um
this is these are the freedoms you're
allowed to do anything but you're not
allowed to uh have Russian Flags or sing
Russian military songs
uh let alone other things you know that
they they've got out there uh and the
question is is this the freedom they all
these people talk about they boast about
I mean you know here in Germany you're
not allowed to sing the first verse of
the national anthem because it says
Germany overall over everybody right and
uh they're a little ashamed of that uh
verse because
specifically because of what Hitler did
right uh they were proud of that verse
in those days but today they're a little
embarrassed by that because it's like
saying oh we're Superior to everybody
else
and so they don't sing that one and so
you have all these prohibitions and uh
self prohibitions like you know we're
not going to sing that verse
and you call that freedom
so uh you know again I I don't think
there's that much difference between the
west and the East that's my personal
opinion okay and I talked about these
two guys the other day you know uh
baltimorean and Al Capone
uh in Chicago 1920s or early 30s
and one guy you know uh bugs he he had
the north side he had that red territory
that's what he controlled uh at some
point our component controlled the South
okay
uh who should you go with uh should you
go with bugs or without I mean who do
you think is better
um vote for one of them for for
president mayor of the city you know uh
no I don't think you would choose any of
them because no one neither one was
better than the other they just did what
they had to do they were businessmen we
say they were murderers assassins that's
what a businessman is if he has to
murder someone he'll do it try to do it
quietly you know we're the right people
uh that's the way democracy functions
okay no difference than uh communism or
any of the others uh supposedly
tyrannical systems out there
and uh so here you have the today's
situation who should you vote for should
you go with bugs or with Al
west side or east side it's always
changes north south to East West right
and bugs uh you know he's got some
credits to his uh or or some points of
his credit right there you have
Hiroshima and you have the West Side
gang uh beating up on Vietnam okay on
the other side you have the Soviets you
could say the Russians again you know
attacked Afghanistan there was a war
there and if I only had to get out and
now you have this Ukraine operation
uh who should you vote for I mean should
it be on the east side or the west side
so you see where I'm headed with all
this
um you know uh
when you pay take sides
uh you're kind of um being brainwashed a
little bit you know it doesn't really
concern you very much it concerns only
the politicians and what they want for
each for for their own country for their
own turf you know uh I'd rather not take
sides anymore I used to take sides not
no more I learned my lesson I hope you
learn yours and here's a final issue for
uh
the yellow of fear okay here we have
NASA desperately trying to mine the moon
before China gets there anyway space
race is warming up between us and China
as each Nation clamors to uh return to
the Moon a new NASA solicitation
reinforces its interest in mining the
moon following previous comments from
NASA administrators about U.S need to
get there first NASA hopes to recruit
University researchers to investigate
ways to use metal mine from the moon's
surface layer there are certain Metals
we might be able to extract in different
parts of the Moon and we might need to
start manufacturing them if we are going
to build things on the moon NASA
administrators said we'd better watch
out that China doesn't get to a place on
the moon under the guise of scientific
research
okay
so uh there's this uh Race to the Moon
to some degree okay some people don't
believe we can get out of the Earth or
even to the moon or any place out there
especially the flat earthers okay uh but
I guess the question is
are you worried about
catching you know yellow fear
and my suggestion to you is don't worry
about it you know
don't worry about it at all because the
United States will never allow China to
catch up with it or to surpass it
before that happens there will there
will be an incident mafias don't allow
uh they've learned their lessons so they
won't allow in this day and age for
another Mafia to take over
uh you know to to surpass them to take
over their turfs it's not going to
happen the United States will be the
last major Empire on Earth and that's
how the world will end
okay that's my five cents worth on that
okay so let's move on to motion what is
motion
well the other day uh we discussed this
this is the uh
Universal movie
and we have on the top the static
Concepts the main static Concepts at the
bottom we have some of the primary and
some lesser or or more sophisticated
Dynamic Concepts so at the top you have
uh Dynamic static Concepts such as
object distance location and existence
and on the bottom you have things like
motion position ether field Etc energy
time
and so we separate the static from the
Dynamic Concepts
what is the difference well static
Concepts you can
see in a single frame of the universal
movie all you have is objects standing
still distance one from each other and
all they have is location all we have
there is existence all static Concepts
what do we need for uh Dynamic Concepts
well we need at least two frames of the
universal movie that's what we're
synthesizing here with this image okay
so as you can see motion is at the
bottom it requires it according to this
two frames of the movie you cannot see
Motion in a single frame of the
universal movie because a single frame
only contains a cross-section of motion
you could say a cross section of time
meaning location only and distance
between or distances between every atom
in the universe that's all we have in
each frame okay okay so that's our
starting point but it turns out that
um
motion you know some people
tried to define it now for hundreds of
thousands of years or so it seems at
least a few thousand years and they
haven't been able to Define motion
and in order to get a handle on this
issue about about motion we have to go
back to at least the days of the Greeks
and probably you know they got a lot of
that stuff from previous civilizations
but we have to start with the Greek
because they did leave some kind of
record that we can relate to
I just can't seem to think that that's
where it all started there probably were
previous uh Generations or civilizations
that you know already discussed what
motion was and a lot of geometry and a
lot of the concepts that the Greeks
somehow heard and then developed even
further so we have to stop start with
the Greeks
and uh one place to start that because
they dealt with this issue in in some
death okay they came up with new
Concepts where the iliadics iliadics
were a uh group of they called them
philosophers they still call them
philosophers that were in the
southwestern part of Italy you know the
boot they were on the southwestern part
and I created this uh little chart to
give you an idea where the different
schools of the Greeks were and we're
going to concentrate today on the
ieliadics and here it is okay here you
see the map of the Mediterranean some of
these other schools which are not
pertinent today you can see them Circle
there but we're going to look at the
iliadic school and specifically at uh
Parmenides and um
Melissa's okay and he lived in that
region of Italy southwestern part of the
boot
and they had a great time coming up with
new Concepts and one of the ones that
they analyzed was the word motion what
is motion is there motion is there
change
okay
and uh one thing I like about Parmenides
you know is that he wasn't able to
figure out something he he wrote a poem
that's all we have from him and then the
rest were analysis of Parmenides by
Aristotle okay but when you look at
Parmenides
um
he uh he wrote a poem called they called
today unnature because there's several
of uh these
poems and so in uh books that they wrote
in the past they had no name so they
call them all on nature okay so uh
Parmenides supposedly wrote on nature
poem in which he put his ideas okay and
was he that Parmenides says is that he
cannot imagine
something moving in opposite directions
okay like you have a ball right well the
ball can't move in opposite direction it
moves one way or the other one direction
right but not two ways
okay it can only move one way okay this
is how he says it this is uh from his
book or his poem parhaminy says
undiscerning crowds in whose eyes all
things travel in opposite direction okay
that's those are undiscerning crowds
right for this shall never be proved
that the things that are not
are
nor lit habit Force
thee to East to uh East a to cast a
Wandering eye upon this devious track or
to turn thither thy resounding ear or
thy tongue but do thou judge the subtle
refutation of their discourse uttered by
me
yeah he could not conceive of something
traveling in opposite directions
it took two thousand years two thousand
plus a year 2 500 years almost to come
up with the Rope model okay yes there is
something that can travel in opposite
directions but it's not a something it's
a signal
that goes along a rope because it hits
both ends at the same time or in
opposite directions at least and all it
has to do is Twirl in place and so you
have a little bit drilling here and a
little bit drilling there you have
drilling on both sides you can say
that's traveling even though there is no
traveling okay but you have impacts on
both ends okay and so yeah in a way uh
you could say it travels in opposite
directions because that's what light
does even though light is both a thing
which is the mediator of light and the
motion it does which is uh troll in situ
but you have uh detection at both ends
so in that sense you could say yeah
light travels quotations on that in
opposite directions but he could not
figure it out okay he he didn't realize
that his grandmother's uh clothesline
was traveling in opposite directions
okay
um so what did uh parmenity say well
he's credited credited okay of saying
the following he says
explain that motion doesn't exist okay
so that's going to be his argument says
void doesn't exist
nothing doesn't exist there's nothing
there so it doesn't exist okay whatever
exists means but he just took it for
granted says the void doesn't exist an
object cannot move into what doesn't
exist
you know you have an empty space it
can't move into an empty space because
the empty space doesn't exist there's
nothing to move into literally nothing
to move into
so therefore motion doesn't exist okay
that was his argument
uh not okay so we scratch it out no uh
that's not what uh his argument was but
that's what a lot of people think today
that parmenity's arguments uh what his
argument was that was taken up by
someone else what permanentes argued was
something else this is what he argued he
says you know motion Demands a starting
point
now you have to have a place where you
start
okay nothing exists before the beginning
before that starting point because that
is your starting point so there's
nothing before that in this case nothing
meaning
uh a something right
before nothing before that starting
point okay beginning implies what
creation of matter if you're gonna have
a beginning you have to have creation of
matter
that's the beginning you know like uh
Big Bang
uh how did the singularity get there
well we don't know but they start at the
where the singularity is already there
what surrounds the singularity what is
the singularity we don't know we don't
care you know all they say is that's
where we start our film and that's more
or less where parmenis is going with
this he's not really talking about
motion
as we will see it's hard to really about
change
okay
and I always say that change in motion
are synonyms there's only a tiny very
tiny difference between them and I'm
going to get to that in a second okay
but let's continue here
this implies that matter had to have a
beginning because that is your starting
point but creation you know from nothing
extra yellow uh is irrational you cannot
conceptualize how something you know how
a rabbit Pops in from the void
surreptitiously
so you cannot create something from
nothing with or without God because even
let's assume God exists we'll remove the
magic wand I'm going to be God for a
second if you don't mind you go poof
right Abracadabra and suddenly you have
the rabbit no problem
how did you make it what's the what's
the uh process give me the what assembly
line did you use to create the the
rabbit
okay what was the process the mechanism
and if you can't answer that well you
know I don't even think God can answer
that okay you can't just say well it
just popped in from nothing
oh you know if nothing converted to
something right then you created
something there was some kind of motion
right you would think right
but uh he says it's irrational you
cannot conceptualize it and I think he's
right okay so therefore motion is
impossible
okay you cannot conceptualize motion
because it has to have a starting point
and a starting point means the creation
of matter and that's erection
that was his argument okay that was a
parmented his argument
okay but uh what was he talking about he
was really talking about change
okay and here let me illustrate what I'm
referring to and why change is not
exactly
the same as motion okay why because
motion we think of one object
okay we think of one object as moving
change does not necessarily I mean 100
99.9999 999s
is the same but there's one instance
that I can think of at least where it's
not the same
okay and that is
when you have absolutely nothing
and you simply make a change and have
something
so it does involve this we will see here
it does involve the universal movie
in one frame you have absolutely nothing
okay
and in the other frame you have
something
did anything move did the ball move well
not really it's not that the ball moved
from one uh location to another what we
see here is that there's something and
suddenly you have appearance
and that existence coming into existence
can we call that motion or is that just
change
okay so we see the difference here
between change and motion okay but this
is an extreme scenario it's the only one
I can think of maybe you can think of
another one right but here we can see
that change involves coming into
existence whereas motion is one object
uh in two frames of the universal movie
you could say that okay that's a way of
putting it
okay the person who actually uh talked
about moving into voids was malicious uh
who came a little after uh Parmenides
and this is what he had to say and for
this he had to create the notion of what
is known as the one
being you know
so he's talking really about the
universe okay what he's going to say his
argument is going to be that the
universe is completely filled with
matter
you could say and space
okay now that's a little tricky here but
since it's all filled not only in space
but in time
it's everything
and if everything is filled
then there can be no motion because
everything's taken up and so something
cannot move into where something else is
push it aside because everything is
completely filled
the universe the one
being okay so he said whatever has a
beginning and end is neither Eternal nor
Unlimited
okay so uh he's gonna start with this
notion that of time okay being has no
beginning or end
no beginning or end therefore it is
eternal and unlimited
he's talking about the universe he's
going to call it the one he's going to
call it being he says it occupies
everything
which already is a problem because if it
occupies everything what is on outside
of it and he's saying there ain't
anything outside of it because it's
Eternal in time
and it's infinite in uh space
so whatever that means because we don't
understand what infinity and time and E
turn
eternity and time and infinity in space
means but this is what he's saying he's
filling up everything
okay
and so therefore it is eternal and
unlimited what is
is temporarily unlimited that's what is
okay therefore nothing else temporarily
nothing else temporarily unlimited could
exist at the same time because this is
everything
God the universe whatever you want to
call it yeah it's everything and if
that's everything there can't be another
thing if that's everything
so forget about you know uh Multiverse
you know many universes no he says this
is everything okay
um
what is is spatially unlimited
so it's not only temporarily uh
unlimited but it's also spatially
unlimited he just made the universe
everything uh in space and time okay
just covers everything whatever
everything is therefore nothing else
spatially unlimited could exist at
different time okay again therefore what
is is one
okay now you got to this one this this
notion of one that he wanted to get
through
okay now he's gonna proceed with the one
okay I hope you're you're following what
uh Melissa is trying to say here okay
here's the one he says whatever
undergoes change is altered
okay I don't know it's I think change
and altered is uh our synonyms right
okay so he says uh the one meaning
everything Universe being whatever you
want to call it God right is Unified and
whole
it's everything therefore the one does
not undergo any type of change because
it's already filled it's in both space
and time it's completely covered right
to be empty is to be nothing
okay whatever empty is because empty is
a synonym of nothing nothing is a
synonym of empty vacuum space whatever
you want to call it what is nothing does
not exist
okay they all had the same idea nothing
does not exist they never Define the
word exist but they said oh you know
what I mean you know nothing it doesn't
exist okay something only can exist
whatever that is okay the one exists
okay now he's saying that the Universe
exists
the everything The
Eternity and the spatial Infinity that
exists right therefore the one is not
empty
okay the everything is not empty
okay this is his logic if you can call
it logic but this is how we started uh
this whole mess okay and so here he
continues he says what is not empty must
be full okay so yeah that sounds logical
there it says therefore the one is full
the universe is full whatever has motion
is not full because you know he's going
to say that motion is gonna mean that
you're gonna move into
a place or a region where there's
nothing okay but it's all full so
there's nowhere to move whatever is full
has no empty spaces must be Motionless
the one is full therefore the one is
Motionless
okay you see uh how he went through all
this so what is uh Melissa saying you
say you know um the universe is full
there's no room for there's no empty
space because empty space does not exist
therefore you cannot talk about motion
because in order to have motion you
should be able to move into nothing but
nothing doesn't exist
therefore there is no motion this is his
reason so in the case of Parmenides
we're talking about change we're saying
it's motion also in general but he's
talking about primarily change something
coming from nothing and in the case of
Melissa's he said you can't move into
nothing because nothing doesn't exist
everything's full therefore there is no
place to no empty space into which to
move
that that's how their reasoning and
that's how we started
okay
um so here uh here we have
uh this all came a little later
Aristotle
and he's going to attack the notion of
motion as well he has nature a principle
of motion and change notion notice that
he separates motion and change like
they're otherwise you would say a
principle of motion or a principle of
change no he says motion and change
meaning or suggesting that they're not
exactly alike whatever he means by
change and again and I think the what
they had going through their mind was
this notion of appearing from the void
coming into existence motion is supposed
to belong to a class of things which are
continuous
okay
infinite is often used in definitions of
the continuous what is infinitely
divisible is continuous
so he has a strange notion of what
continuous is he says continues is what
is something next to each other so he's
saying in continuous is what's chopped
up into pieces basically numbers he was
thinking of numbers okay so he said one
next to the other that's called
continues to him
in physics we have a different notion
continuous is that which is made of a
single piece
but he's saying continuous is that which
is exactly the opposite segmented or
partitioned and but one is next to the
other because again he's thinking of
numbers okay it says Place void and time
are necessary conditions of motion
well I'm not going to discuss place and
void
but certainly uh time is not a necessary
condition for motion it's the other way
around motion is a necessary condition
of time
time is the comparison of two motions
motion you move as we will see if you
occupy two locations so no we don't need
time to Define motion and that was one
of his big errors okay
and here we see
he tries to Define what motion is
Aristotle okay she says the Fulfillment
of what exists potentially
is motion
he had two Notions of motion one is the
potential and the other one is the
natural motion what is the emotion that
an object has
by itself
he was thinking of gravity you let go of
the pencil and it doesn't stay up there
it has motion all of its own natural
motion and then the other one is that
while you hold the pencil
it has potential motion
which materializes when you let go
then it falls okay so this is the notion
that he had a motion what is alterable
or what can be increased in and it's
opposite decreased right what can come
to be and can pass away
and what can be carried along meaning
Locomotion those are the Notions of
motion that good old Airy had uh
2 200 300 years ago
okay uh hundreds of years later another
fellow attacked the notion of motion
what is motion that was Renee Descartes
and he made a big mess of it just like
everybody else okay you never figured it
out but this is what he had to say
and how he justified it he says motion
is nothing more than the what action I
thought action was motion by which a
body passes I thought passes was motion
from one place to another oh great uh I
guess he broke his head on this one he's
defining motion as motion let's replace
the action passes with motion the motion
is nothing more than the motion by which
a body moves from one place to another
[Laughter]
that's what he that's what he said
how does he justify it well he justified
something else he's he's giving you here
a little clue on how he's reasoning this
says the same thing may be said to
change and not to change place at the
same time so how can that possibly be he
says so also we may say that the same
thing is at the same time moved and not
moved
okay how does he justify this is a
person seated in a vessel which is
setting sail thinks he is in motion if
he looks to the shore that he has left
and considered it as fixed but not if he
regard the ship itself among the parts
of which he preserves always the same
situation in other words you're in this
little cabin in the on a boat right and
you don't move with respect to the cabin
but you're moving with respect to the
shore because the boat is moving along
the water so he's saying you you move
and not move at the same time you're
moving with respect to the shore but
you're not moving with respect to the
cabin okay moreover because we are
accustomed to suppose that there is no
motion without action and that in rest
there is the cons the cessation of
action the person thus seated is more
property said to be at rest than in
motion seeing he is not conscious of
being in action again that's what
happens when you introduce observers
into your discussion that's why we kill
observers in physics we do it Mafia
style we we wipe out the witness because
that's what happened when you introduce
observers and you talk about observation
you're observing that you're standing
still but your observation is wrong
because you're moving with respect to
the coast
okay so are you moving or not moving
well both I'm moving with respect to the
coast but I'm not moving with respect to
the cabin and so they end up with these
contradictions saying well you move and
not move at the same time
and why and because of that you know
they end up with the wrong Notions or
the Run definitions of what motion is
and here we have another guy who gave it
a try and failed miserable his name is
Isaac Newton some of you know him okay
and he says he talks about place okay
and place to him is not the same thing
as position okay he's going to make a
tiny distinction there place is a part
of space which a body takes up
uh it's what we call position okay or at
least in physics position is the same
thing as the object
the object itself is position because
it's like the fish uh is in the water
and it displaces water the volume of
water that the fish displaces
so is that true in space
you know the fish
occupy space meaning it you know it uh
occupies that volume displaces something
and the answer is no because space is
nothing and so the fish does not
displace anything therefore the fish is
it the position itself because there is
no displacement of any material entity
when a fish occupies space when it
occupies water yes there is displacement
but not in space because space is
nothing okay
okay so it says
um and is according to the space either
absolute or rotted I say part of space
not the situation nor the external
surface of the Body for the places of
equal solids are always equal but
they're super fizzes by reason of their
dissimilar figures are often unequal and
then he clarifies here there's a little
difference between place and position
positions properly have no quantity
nor are they so much the places
themselves as the properties of places
okay so I think he's referring here to
the Cartesian coordinates uh who came
before him right and so it's like the
ordered pair is the position which is
what mathematicians call today position
right and place is the physical
supposedly volume occupied by the object
so you have to think of it in those
terms
so what did uh Mr uh Newton conclude
after thinking so deeply well he
concludes the following he says I do not
Define time space place and motion as
being well known to all
so he never defined motion because he
had no idea what motion was
and yet he's credited with discovering
the three laws of motion
which is not true either because
Descartes Galileo already had talked
about the three laws of motion of Newton
okay
okay so what is motion today what have
we learned from all these great
luminaries right and here it is this is
the definition we have today motion the
action
ring a bell or process it looks like
those two already have motion of moving
oh I love that one
motion is moving okay I always wanted to
know or of changing place or position
movement
great we've learned a lot so what is
action well the process or state of
acting or being active what is a process
a systematic series of actions directed
to some man a continuous action
operation of our series of changes
taking place in a definite manner what
is moving capable of or be having
movement great love all these
definitions they're all synonyms
movement the act or process or result of
moving what has changed to make the form
nature content future course of
something different from what it is or
from what it could would be if left
alone meaning that all of these are
synonyms all they said is motion is
motion motion means moving motion is
movement
we learn a lot with that motion is
action motion is a process
yeah so so they have no definitions
today
you will not find a definition of the
word motion a scientific definition of
the word Motion in any textbook of
physics at the high school or college
level ever on planet Earth okay
so we don't know what motion is because
they Define it using synonyms and when
you look up those words you find out
they all contain the word motion
that's where that's where we're at today
so let's find out if we can find out
what motion is okay here it is
motion two locations of an object right
you need two frames of the universal
movie now here uh the uh yellow dot ball
whatever you want to call that is uh
gauge with respect to the position the
location right is gauge with respect to
the frame of the film but the way we
have to look at this is that uh an atom
any atom any existing atom simply has
distance with respect to all other atoms
in the universe
okay and so there's distance between
them and when that distance uh in other
words in the in the next frame of the
movie locations change
of every atom in the universe now you
have motion you have two locations
that is the definition of motion and not
the action or the process or whatever
other synonyms people put it in there
okay so let's uh see if we can find out
how these definitions come together here
it is
object that which has shape
not that which you can see it or touch
distance
separation between objects
we're talking about physics here so what
we're looking at separation that's
distance distance is not unrolling the
measuring tape and Counting meters
that's not this and that's distance
traveled of the end of the tape
or how many tiles you put between two
things the that's that's already you
know that's motion that's Dynamic that's
a dynamic concept here we're saying
distance just separation Gap okay chasm
location the set of distances from one
atom for example to all the other atoms
in the universe okay now you have
distance uh set of distances and motion
two or more locations two locations of
an object
that's how they come together now we
have a definition that you can sink your
teeth into and not have to rely on
synonyms if they as they have been uh
using for the last at least 2500 years
okay
okay so let's go on with our uh
science critic
and our science critic had to this time
talks about knowledge
and Truth he says that science is about
knowledge science is about truth
but then he's going to go in there and
say that knowledge is belief truth is
belief
and I guess that means that science is
about belief
I thought it was religion that was about
belief that you had to go to church or
somewhere I guess to pray and have
belief
science is about belief let's find out
this is what he's got to say and we're
going to start with uh my questions on
on what we're analyzing today which is
knowledge in uh truth here it goes give
me a second okay
here goes
no questions and issues to be addressed
today include
is science about knowing
about knowledge
is science about truth
Ismail is just belief
that is an opinion
and is truth just an opinion
the science of today could be shown to
be false tomorrow but the only way that
we could find out if science is false
is by obtaining more knowledge if
someone shows that your knowledge is
wrong then that will no longer be a
Justified true belief you can have a
Justified true belief that is incorrect
because something being true does not
mean that it's correct although that is
quite a philosophical Rabbit Hole to
dive down which involves talking about
what exactly is truth and this is kind
of the point that I'm getting at about
truth what one person considers to be
true may be entirely different to what
another person considers to be true
okay
I think this uh poor fellow just uh went
around in circles
shot himself in the foot
uh and here's a synthesis of what he
said or what he thinks he said I don't
think he even paid attention or listened
to what he said here it is uh he says
science is knowledge okay science is
truth but knowledge is believe and Truth
is belief because it's all opinion
everybody has their own truth right
therefore belief which is opinion right
and science apparently ends up being
belief
right and did I miss something here you
started out with knowledge which is
belief Justified true belief but he says
you can prove to someone that his belief
is wrong but the question is what if you
don't prove to him that he's wrong what
if he continues to believe in his that
he's got the knowledge that his
knowledge is better than yours or that
he's got a different knowledge than
yours and you can't convince him which
again shows that knowledge is a matter
of opinion you know uh some people know
that God exists and other people know
that God doesn't exist and so uh who's
going to be the the judge is it going to
be God or the devil or Mother Nature
who's going to decide that
so again we have a problem because
um you know this fellow starts out by
saying science is knowledge and Truth
both of which are belief meaning opinion
and they and I guess if you follow his
train of thought you end up with belief
uh and the question is whether that's
what science is about whether it's about
belief
and then he talks about you know
convincing people persuading them that
their knowledge is wrong
and fine if you can convince them then
show that his Justified true belief
wasn't Justified or was not truth or
whatever
and it turns out that all you're doing
is uh working on belief
so if that's what uh uh convincing
someone that his belief that his
Justified true belief is wrong or not
justified right that's not true or
Justified or knowledge at all
you end up with belief anyways no matter
how you twist and turn it
and so all I can say is that you know
these people chase their tails around
they don't even they can't even figure
out that what they're doing what they're
saying that they're completely
irrational in their analysis
science has nothing to do with knowledge
even though the word uh science comes
from you know the word knowledge that's
where it originates but our forefathers
just screwed that one up they had no
idea no science is not about knowledge
science is about uh explaining you
explain them especially as it relates to
physics so about explaining a mechanism
and do we know for a fact
that uh what we that the the science
that the explanation right is true that
it's a fact that it's knowledge no we
don't
we simply state objectively
what the mechanism is
and then so that you understand
then you go out on your own you figure
out if you're going to believe that
version or not you might want to believe
another version you know some people
believe that uh space-time is what
causes gravity and they know for a fact
that's the case
and other people say no that's that's
false that's not true
and we proved that we proved it with an
experiment yeah I'm sorry
I don't buy it I I don't believe
and so uh the question is you know who's
right
and there is no right or wrong that's
why science does not deal with right
wrong correcting correct true truth fact
knowledge belief all that is religion
all that is religion science is only
explanation objective explanation
so that you understand
you like it you don't like it science
doesn't care that's that's for church
people church goers to figure out
okay
okay uh let's get to the questions here
we have one fellow who sent me this
says I have come to believe that the
motion of the earth cannot be detected
by an optical experiment
and yes this comes from a flat earther
okay
and so he's throwing this at The
Establishment saying when you can't
prove it in an experiment it's called a
belief
well if you prove it with an experiment
isn't it also a belief
so this is what they can't figure out
that you have belief either way
proof means belief proof means you
convince someone he you proved it to him
if anything right let's assume you're
successful then you proved it to him
you know the other fellow next to him
his neighbor he doesn't believe
despite the experiment he or he comes up
with a different conclusion especially
on invisible intangible mediators and
phenomena like gravity or magnetism you
can't see it you can't you can't touch
it
so there's no way to run an experiment
and uh and say I proved it and if you
did prove it to someone
all you did was convince him meaning you
worked on his belief not not on not on
his understanding science is about
explaining and understanding not about
proving and believing
but they don't understand this this is
what they don't have to say their
knowledge is still uh you know uh in its
infancy
here we have another flat earther and he
says something different or something
similar I guess you could say if Earth
was spinning
this guy meaning the helicopter right
could stay right here for 12 hours and
then on the other side of the planet
you know because if you have the Earth
spinning the guy just stays there right
he's going to end up on the other side
this is their logic
if you can call it logic
uh yeah there's something called gravity
you know every atom of that helicopter
is bound to every atom on Earth so when
the Earth moves guess what all the atoms
of the air move and all the atoms of the
helicopter move with the Earth as well
so the Earth does drag things around
like you know satellites but yeah flat
earthers I believe in satellites either
so we can't help them there
okay
um is one fellow he says the following
says what is an object without location
well we have to go through the
definitions okay just
you know stay uh fixed with the
definition don't uh you know go on a
detour don't escape the definitions by
even at one Yoda okay object that which
has shape distance separation between
two objects it's just separation
location the set of distances one object
to all the others and exist is object
that has location physical presence
therefore an object without location is
what an object that doesn't exist
okay existence requires object and
location
object does not require location
okay existence requires that so if an
object does not have location it's an
object that doesn't exist
if God has location God exists by
definition
if God does not have location okay God
does not exist pursuant to the
definition see how easy it is
piece of cake once you have the
definitions in place
um it doesn't allow you to take a detour
to escape the conclusions okay
so let me get this one out of here give
me a second here
okay here's another fella he says the
following he says rational explanations
of behaviors
in other words why someone did something
that is psychology and not philosophy
well philosophy is uh rational
explanations of behaviors just like it
says there and it includes a branch of
philosophy known as psychology
so psychology is one branch of
philosophy
but if you don't like the definition of
philosophy as rational explanations of
behavior and problem Define philosophy
then we know what you're what's going
through your tiny little mind okay it's
no use for you to say it's not
philosophy because you haven't defined
philosophy
please you find philosophy and we'll
know what you're talking about okay
again people use these verses they
always tell me what it ain't you say
what's The Ether well no that you got it
wrong bill that's not what the ether is
okay don't tell me what it what it ain't
tell me what it is
and they never do what is plasma don't
tell me what it ain't tell me what it is
for state of matter or whatever tell me
what tell me what it is that's what we
want to know don't don't tell me what it
ain't and this all just says it ain't
uh
philosophy because you're talking about
psychology well we don't know if it's
not philosophy because you haven't
defined philosophy
okay here's another felon he says nobody
wants to live for 200 years which is
what I said the other day speak for
yourself
well there we have Good Old Rip Van wink
going he overslept like 20 years when he
woke up you know uh everything had
changed you know uh King George the
third was not the king of the United
States right it was uh there was another
king his name was Georgie Washington and
can you imagine sleeping for 200 years
we're not even sleeping 200 years but
even living 200 years right
you would experience many changes in
your life
and the question is whether you know you
would tolerate a lot of that stuff like
you know uh bring someone from the 19th
century today
uh do you think he would be a little
startled
and and even if he saw the progress of
all the changes that happened in the
last 200 years
he'd be out of his mind he would be
blown out of you know out of smithereens
they'd say what's going on here you know
I mean I started with a with a wagon and
the horses and look we had we have
airplanes flying and cars and
and telephones
so you can imagine the impact on someone
who lives 200 years
be terrible it really would be uh thank
God or thank Mother Nature or father
Universe one of those guys uh that give
us limited time on Earth maybe 80 90 at
the most maybe 100 years you know in
general
um I think that's that's a lot of time
we beat almost every animal on earth
very few animals live as long as humans
do so uh be happy that
god mother nature the devil one of those
Smiled On Us and allows us to live so
long okay you're living too long as it
is I've lived too too long I want to die
one of these days you know it's the time
to go
okay here's another phone he says the
trouble is you think you have time
yeah we start out as babies and we grow
old and old and older
and
uh yeah it's like you don't have enough
time and then time runs out one day it's
no longer there
for you and for others it continues but
the question is you know is it possible
that at some point for our species
time Runs Out
we were a young species we had 200 300
000 years ago
and now we are an old species we're an
old species because we have lost our
genetic diversity we have very little
genetic diversity meaning uh we went
through it very fast partly because we
grew exponentially and last 200 300
years okay the population on Earth has
ballooned of humans right and I think
all that's got a bearing on uh where
we're headed and I think uh we're about
to expire our clock is about to uh drop
the last grain of sand we're that close
okay what is it called the uh
the
clock uh the uh clock approaching
midnight I can't remember the name the
uh
what is it the clock
um the nuclear clock yeah whatever it's
called I can't remember right now but
anyways uh that's that's what it is
we're we're approaching the day of
of the Judgment as it used to be called
We're approaching the end of man and so
we all have to get used to the idea that
we're not going to live forever now some
people say you know uh I don't believe
in your theory Bill okay no problem
um you know I don't think we're the last
humans on Earth
and uh but they believe that maybe
humans will come to an end someday and
have a little contradiction or at least
I want to make them aware of something
and that is that when you say that it's
like the captain of the ship
who doesn't want to go down with his
ship even though he crashed it
and he says no no forget about the women
and the children I'm going to save my
life and he gets on the bone he rose
away and lets the ship come down with
children and women and whatever
no the captain has to go down with the
that's the protocol that's the
ethical way of doing things and when
you're saying that you don't want to be
the last generation on Earth you don't
want to be less human on earth you don't
want to be in in the last group of
humans that live on earth all you're
saying is you want your son to be or
your grandson to be the last guy on
earth
you're just shoving the responsibility
unto someone else you're leaving the
children and the women on the boat and
you're trying to save your life Your
Hide
that's the context okay so keep that